[Music]
wikipedia it is a fascinating thing
today that wikipedia is as trusted as it
is misused by as many people as it is
because if you think about how an
encyclopedia that anyone could edit
could possibly grow to be a resource
that about a billion it gets about a
billion visits every single month from
all over the globe there's a story of
constant self improvement in there a
story of really grappling with our flaws
and with our faults along the way
wikipedia wasn't trusted when it first
started because it was the encyclopedia
anyone could edit and then we had a
series of fairly high-profile mistakes
hoaxes screw-ups the thing that makes
Wikipedia work is that the Wikipedia
community is so committed to getting it
right that when errors happen their
first responses to fix them so there's
this story from 2005 when a journal
nature which is a scientific journal did
a study a sample study on how accurate
Wikipedia articles are and the study
found that on average the articles of
bay surveyed were about as accurate as a
relative sample set from encyclopedia
britannica and the story of this goes
that when this was published the
Wikipedia community went to jimmy wales
the founder and asked if he could put
them in touch with the editors at nature
so they could find out where the errors
were so they could fix them and I think
that is such a classic example of
wikipedians when they find out that
something's wrong their first response
is not to get defensive their first
response is generally delight because it
means that there's something to improve
the whole conversation around fake news
is a bit perplexing to the comedians
because bad information has always
existed and the very first press freedom
law was passed more than 250 years ago
in Sweden and I bet the very first
conversation about misinformation
happened about within that first year
yellow journalism missing from
Nation propaganda however you want to
name it there are already names for fake
news and there are ways of dealing with
some established ways of dealing with
them so for wikipedians we look at this
and we say this has been a problem since
time immemorial and for the last 16
years we've been working on sorting back
from fiction and doing a pretty good job
of it so to have this conversation I
think is is a little bit disingenuous
because it is looking at fake news as
though it's the problem instead of
actually looking at some of the
commercial and other factors that go
enter into play around the distribution
of information the obstacle the source
of information the consolidation of the
media landscape the commercial pressures
on publishers that have been created by
major platform distributors the lack of
transparency in the way information is
presented through algorithmic feeds and
why there is an interest in these
platforms and doing this it's really not
about the quality of information itself
bad information has always existed I
would certainly say the media landscape
in media literacy are important and it
is a call to arms for us to be more
engaged in education around civics and
media literacy but I also think it's an
opportunity to have hard conversations
with platforms that present information
within algorithmically curated feeds
about why they aren't presenting some
critical information that allows people
to make good decisions about
understanding where that information
comes from one thing that we would point
to within Wikipedia is that all of the
information that is presented you can
scrutinize you can understand where it
comes from you can check the citations
you can also check almost every single
edit that has ever been made to the
projects in their 16 years of existence
and those are more than 3 billion edits
all of that is available to the public
we hold ourselves up to scrutiny because
we think that scrutiny and transparency
creates accountability and that
accountability creates trust when i'm
looking at a Facebook feed I don't know
why information is being presented to me
is because it's timely is it because
it's relevant is it because it's
trending popular important all of that
is stripped out of context so it's hard
for me to assess is it good information
that I should make decisions on is it
bad information that I should ignore and
then you think about the fact that all
of the other sort of heuristics that
people use to interpret information
where does it come from who wrote it
when was it published all of that is
obscured in the product design as well
so the conversation that we're having I
think is a bit disingenuous because it
doesn't actually address some of the
underlying platform questions and
commercial pressure questions it tends
to focus on you know I'm not even sure
oh and then to focus on educating the
end consumer which is good we believe in
an educated user but we also have a lot
of confidence that if you give the user
the information they need they can make
those decisions and determinations
[Music]